welcome back it is 6 15 and we're
continuing our wayne newton week we're
talking to mr las vegas about more than
just his incredible singing career he
has appeared in some 55 motion pictures
countless tv shows some have even
inspired little script changes and
well unique fan requests here's what he
told me about one movie you are no doubt
familiar with
[Music]
you have cameos and some of my favorite
movies and i love that you're always
you're willing to have a little fun you
know and sometimes at your own expense
i'm thinking you know vegas vacation or
the hangover or some of these other ones
how fun is that to just be yourself it's
great fun except that i'm i'm not myself
that's the problem in vegas vacation
they had me given ellen uh a gift
and and it was a keychain with my
picture on the keychain
and again i
i said uh
wayne newton wouldn't do that
he said what what do you do
i said
give me two minutes and we'll do the
scene over
i went upstairs and i said to the
girl doing makeup
cut my hair here
she said what i said just cut my hair
here
and keep it
and tie bow around it and put that in
the keychain well that was your idea to
this day
i get letters
and even people in line after the show
for the meet and greet saying
could i have a strand of your hair so do
you oblige occasionally oh yes really oh
yes
uh
and so when i do get my hair cut back
my barber knows to
brush it up and keep it put it in the
bag
and so
we have sent those to
certain people that
it really meant something to
but i always get a kick out of it
i certainly do
so there you have it if you ask nicely
maybe you'll get a lock of mr las vegas
hair